[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening everyone and welcome to the
beautiful Beverly Wilshire ballroom and
the Academy's 86th scientific and
technical awards
the first time these awards became a
standalone dinner presentation was on
March 29 1978 in the Grand Ballroom of
the Beverly Hilton Kirk Douglas and
Gregory Peck hosted but the side tech
awards go back to the earliest days of
the Academy when they were first
presented as part of the regular awards
dinner at the Biltmore Hotel on November
10 1931 Oscar statuettes were given to
RCA photophone and to RKO studios for
noise reduction recording imagine pre
Dolby and to DuPont film and to the
Eastman Kodak Company for the
manufacture of super-sensitive
panchromatic films these awards have
always had their own ambience separate
from that other red carpet show over on
Hollywood Boulevard
for example the buzz this evening will
not be who is wearing what designer
label but will address far more
consequential matters such as do most
filmmakers really need the tank sized 73
foot Hydra scope self-leveling
telescoping camera crane
or can we squeak by with merely the 32
foot model or even more momentous should
we in hindsight have had a bake-off
between DreamWorks and Pixar Animation
Studios over the Primeau or the presto
character animation systems I'm hoping
that committee chair ray Feeny along
with our resident arbiter that most
articulate spokesman of many things
techno mr. Jonathan Arlen will enlighten
us as he embraces the Oscar statuette
he'll receive this evening
there's no one here who has done more
for our community with his ongoing
analysis of image creation the movies
may be a visual medium but Jonathan is
one of its best wordsmiths
I've been so looking forward to this
evening as awards to tell you my fellow
filmmakers here tonight just how crucial
your work is to the so intricate warp
and woof of today's motion pictures at
every phase of production and post the
amazing tools of Science and Technology
that you continue to develop carry us
ever outward into new and alternative
visions into new worlds and into the
mysteries of our own psyches just where
would our great actors and writers our
directors and producers be without the
amazingly complex hardware and software
creations that you set out before us
this is your night nobody's going to
play you off into a commercial break
the Academy its officers and Board of
Governors are here to recognize and
honor the amazing work you do even
though most of us sitting here have no
idea how to describe it one person who
can step up to this high-tech assignment
is our eloquent host for this evening a
near thirty year veteran of the Royal
Shakespeare Company captain of the
Starship Enterprise
[Music]
hello Academy mer and proud Olympic
torch bearer Patrick Stewart
sir Patrick thank you for being with us
here tonight I want to recognize also
the Academy governors our CEO Don Hudson
as well as past and present members and
project contributors of the SciTech
Council and its director Andy malts this
year
this year we have seen a wider adoption
of the academy color encoding system
aces now for large and for small budget
movies several of which have been
nominated for Academy Awards also the
Society of motion picture and television
engineers simply published this year to
standards based on aces to help with the
long term preservation of our digital
movies a step closer to solving the
dreaded digital dilemma some of us
however might be presumptuous enough to
ask while waiting for this elusive
digital solution there is already a
reliable analog preservation medium
maybe you've heard about it it's called
film
thanks to the scientific and technical
awards committee in its chair ray Feeny
who has the help of volunteers have
committed countless hours to evaluating
and recommending recipients of tonight's
awards when the Academy Museum of Motion
Pictures opens to the world next year be
assured that the story of motion picture
Science and Technology will be every bit
as crucial to its presentation to the
story of our movies as our Dorothy's red
shoes the rosebud sled and 2001's lunar
lander lander and now it's my honor to
introduce the chair of the scientific
and technical Awards Committee for time
scientific and technical Award winner
and Gordon E Sawyer Oscar recipient mr.
Ray Feeny
[Music]
[Applause]